an attorney a woman married to a
therapist had a baby delivered a baby
and was such a Philadelphia Eagles fan
that she literally watched the game
while she delivered the child the team
won the haven't won since she's thinking
of having another baby to time it to the
playoffs just in case is there a more
perfect example in the world of our
surrogate warriors going to battle in
the name of our tribes and how rapidly
we need to belong to and demonstrate
loyalty in our tribe than the
penultimate sporting event the Super
Bowl we as social animals depend on our
tribes are groups the groups of people
with which we most affiliate for our
safety and our survival we can't protect
ourselves from the lion if the Lions
attacking but together we can so we do
lots of things to demonstrate loyalty to
our various tribes our political tribes
are religious tribes are gender or our
age well our tribe of team mostly based
on geography but a little bit on history
where we grew up let's say that's
exactly their role they are the
surrogate representatives of going to
combat in the name of our tribe so go
Patriots in my case but they're out of
it go Denver go Carolina Go Red Sox go
yankees it's surrogate for go my group
which demonstrates loyalty to the group
which makes the other people in your
group like you you're a Denver fan and
you're living in to England you're going
to get kicked out of the party and
social cohesion helps your group do
better against other groups so in
politics that helps your party win but
in sports you pretend you're the 12th
man you can affect the outcome by how
loudly you scream or how you
sit on the chair did you wear your lucky
hat or did you have omelets your lucky
omelets for breakfast it's a classic
example of how humans depend on their
tribe and their social sense of
belonging for their own sense of safety
and literally survival